[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue d'un point de
vue nous allons revenir sur quelques
événements passionnants du jour mais
aussi de ce week end je vous propose de
découvrir tout de suite le sommaire de
cette émission nous reviendrons sur le
grand discours prononcé par la pression
de la république samedi sur l'égalité
femmes hommes
à l'occasion de la journée
internationale pour l'élimination de la
violence à l'égard des femmes plusieurs
propositions mais des critiques quelques
polémiques
nous en parlerons nous reviendrons
également sur la décision de trois
responsables des républicains dont deux
ministres et le député thierry solère de
passer à la république en marche
est ce une clarification ou une trahison
nous essaierons de trancher nous
reviendrons aussi sur les
la france insoumise qui réunissait sa
convention ce week end c'était à
clermont ferrand
le moral n'est pas au beau fixe les
tensions se font jour à l'intérieur de
ce parti est ce justifié
le seront de faire le point nous
parlerons enfin de la décision qui vient
d'être annoncé par l'union européenne de
prolonger pour cinq ans l'utilisation du
glyphosate ce fameux produits
d'élimination des saletés en général et
des mauvaises âmes en particulier dans
les champs européens est ce que la
france était contre
est ce que c'est une bonne décision ou
non nous allons en discuter avec nos
quatre invités deux hommes deux femmes
de chaque côté du plateau pour éviter
les soupçons de harcèlement bonsoir vous
êtes la coprésidence oui je sais j'ai
osé bancomer que vous êtes la
coprésidente la fondation verte
européenne votre dernier livre la france
résiste-t-elle à l'écologie est paru aux
éditions du bord de l'eau en 2016
bonsoir et me leclerc
vous êtes directeur d'études chez
l'institut de sondage au doxa anne fulda
bonsoir vous êtes grand reporter au
figaro responsable de la rubrique
portraits journaliste politique mais pas
seulement et votre dernier livre
emmanuel macron un jeune homme si
parfait est paru il ya quelques mois aux
éditions plon et bonsoir jean christophe
buisson directeur adjoint du figaro
magazine
votre dernier livre 1917 l'année qui a
changé le monde et est paru chez perrin
c'était l'année dernière
nous allons donc reparler du discours du
président de la république et surtout
des propositions qu'il a faites pour
lutter contre le harcèlement
le chef de l'état a annoncé samedi un
certain nombre de mesures mais il a
aussi appelé à faire attention à ce
qu'il a qualifié de risque de délation
je propose de réécouter un court extrait
du discours du chef de l'état
je veux cette force de la république
parce que je ne veux pas une société de
la délation est aussi vrai que le
silence assourdissant existe encore dans
certains endroits de la république
je ne veux pas que nous tombions dans un
quotidien de la délation qui n'est pas
notre république
alors
cette prise de position a pas fait une
année de paix c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire notamment chez un certain
nombre de militantes féministes en
particulier caroline de haas qui n'est
plus visible d'entre elles qui disait
que parler de délation c'est en fait
donné raison aux agresseurs
ça a valu à là dit caroline de haas un
tweet assez fort de marée tire pas la
secrétaire d'état à l'égalité
femmes-hommes nom caroline de haas vous
instrumentalisez vous déformez jusqu'à
plus soif vous montez les unes contre
les autres
c'est un peu dommage que ça tourne au
pugilat ce moment qui aurait dû être
plutôt un moment d'unité
mais si le smi je crois que ça montre
aussi que depuis plusieurs semaines on
vit au rythme des réseaux sociaux qui
sont un outil démocratique qui fait
vraiment partie de l'époque et qui en
même temps n'aide pas à comprendre ou à
donner le sentiment qu'on peut résoudre
certains sujets qui sont des sujets
compliqués donc je pense que quand
emmanuel macron dit qu'il veut pas de
société de la délation il emploie un
terme très conceptuel et à mon avis
c'est un tort je pense qu'il aurait dû
être plus concret d'ailleurs ce discours
est à mon avis insuffisamment concret en
fait sur les mesures de politiques
publiques il est président de la
république donc il doit donner des
éléments par exemple sur la police la
justice sur lesquels il a été interpellé
en dehors des questions de hashtag donc
je pense que là dessus
ce n'était pas le moment en fait de
faire de la de la philosophie et la
société de la délation ça ça rappelle
quelque chose historiquement ça rappelle
la collaboration ça rappelle des mauvais
souvenirs historiques alors que là on
est dans un moment il faut dire des
choses très concrètes très opérationnel
parce que la question des violences
faites aux femmes
c'est des femmes qui expérimente le fait
qu'elles sont violés qu'elles peuvent
mourir sous les coups de leur conjoint
etc
donc je pense qu'il aurait pas dû
essayer de prendre trop de hauteur pour
être franche et qu'il aurait dû faire un
discours plus opérationnel il me semble
qu'il prend acte d'un malaise réel qui
existent dans la société française
depuis quelques semaines il fait 1h25 de
discours pour annoncer effectivement des
mesures assez forte des moyens
supplémentaires pour lutter contre l'
contre l'inégalité hommes femmes contre
le harcèlement que l'agression sexuelle
mais il prend acte d'un malaise qui est
qu on al impression avec l'embrasement
médiatique existe depuis plusieurs
semaines
qu'on est con a basculé dans une sorte
de de oued de loi des suspects de 1793
où on peut dénoncer des gens sur les
réseaux sociaux comme vous l'avez
signalé sans passer par la case de
police sans passer par la case justice
alors que la police la justice sont là
pour résoudre ce type de problème avec
des enquêtes pas seulement le témoignage
de quelqu'un qui dit j'ai été harcelée
ça c'est la première chose et ça il en a
pris acte et je pense qu'il faut lui
rendre grâce de ça et la deuxième chose
c'est qu'on a un sentiment qu'il ya plus
de proportionnalité dans les actes c'est
à dire que un ministre la défense
britannique obligé de démissionner parce
qu'il a mis l'île a accusé d'avoir mis
la main sur le genou d'une famille à 15
ans par rapport à la fonction qu'il
occupe dans la société britannique où il
ya du terrorisme etc
je trouve qu'il ya quand même un
problème de hiérarchie c'est à dire que
si la moindre accusation a une valeur
policière juridique maintenant même ce
réseau social ça peut vraiment un
problème dans nos sociétés démocratiques
je pense que en faisant cette référence
effectivement à la délation mais il
aurait pu parler de la lettre de cachet
si vous voulez de l'ancien régime ou de
la loi des suspects de 93 de la terreur
il a raison parce qu'on est en train de
partir il me semble dans une dimension
qui me paraît assez démesurée permettez
un tac au tac un guillaume je pense que
le sujet c'est qu'aujourd'hui la police
et la justice
lorsqu'on est une femme harcelée
lorsqu'on est une femme victime de
violences on a le sentiment qu'ils
allaient serait inefficace
donc je crois que ce n'est pas seulement
un sentiment c'est qu'enfin s'il faut
que je justifie ce les termes que
j'emploie sentir absolument terminer ce
que j'ai à dire merci
ce que je veux dire par là c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il ya une forme d'une
efficacité des politiques publiques sur
lesquelles à mon sens un président de la
république un gouvernement doivent se
prononcer et à mon sens aussi il est
assez glissante employer le terme de
délation le problème qu'on a c'est qu'au
fond il ya des actes de nature assez
différente qui ont été dénoncés et que
du coup des choses très graves
on peut être mélangé à des choses qui
donnent le sentiment ce que vous venez
de dire sur le ministre par exemple moi
je pense que s'il a démissionné c'est
peut-être qu'ils avaient des choses
qu'on ne savait pas donc on peut aussi
penser que sur les choses graves
il est temps d'être efficace et à mon
avis si ce ras-le-bol des femmes est
devenue aussi général c'est qu'il
recouvre quelque chose de réel mais la
question c'est est-ce que du coup
on va tellement loin dans cette
dénonciation qu'on va trop loin je
voudrais vous montrer une vidéo qui a
été publié par le secrétariat d'état
pour l'égalité femmes hommes
et comme je suis pas journaliste très
objectif je vais vous le dire moi cette
vidéo l m'a un peu choqué mais je
voudrais avoir votre avis regardez alors
qu'il faille punir les agressions
sexistes
évidemment c'est nécessaire est ce
qu'une main 50 prison et 75000 euros
pour une main aux fesses c'est pas
beaucoup et pardon de le dire c'est pas
trop anne fulda c'est vrai que comme ça
ça semble disproportionnée alors après
il ya ce que peut entraîner un tel
comportement
il faut quand même reconnaître à
emmanuel macron le fait qu'il a un
discours qui en la matière qui est
peut-être excessif et par certains côtés
et imprécis par d'autres néanmoins il
prend acte et il est crédible par
rapport à ses prédécesseurs je dirais
parce qu'effectivement c'est un homme
qui je pense fondamentalement
estime que hommes et femmes se sont il
ya une vraie égalité entre hommes et
femmes qui considère sa femme d'égal à
égal qui a été c'est un homme qui a été
élevé au sens à tous les sens du terme
par des femmes même si on pourrait peut
noter que dans l'entourage présidentiel
il n'y a pas énormément de femmes cela
dit
donc on peut lui au moins lui lui lui
accorder ce crédit je pense qu il
il est sincère dans l'année dans la
nécessité qu'il faille faire quelque
chose
alors après c'est vrai qu'ils moi j'ai
pas envie que la france devienne les
deviennent comme les états unis quoi de
vienne a veillé comme les états unis
même si je pense qu'effectivement quand
il ya des excès il a rappelé des
chiffres quand même 123 femmes qui sont
qui on est et qui sont mortes en 2016
225 mille femmes qui ont été victimes de
violences sexuelles ou autres donc il ya
un vrai problème mais il faut pas
effectivement que ça qu'on entre dans un
dans un système où hommes et femmes se
deviennent des espèces de d'ennemis qui
se regardent en chiens de faïence ou la
suspicion règne
moi je crains ça et je trouve qu'il a
bien fait dire qu'il faut pour nous il
faut pas qu'on entend dans une société
de la délation je trouve qu'il a raison
mais les fléaux est ce que c'est c'est
ce débat qu'on a sur ce plateau on le
ressent dans la société française cadet
dans l'opinion des gens qui trouvent
qu'on va trop loin ou bien au contraire
il faut être assez il faut être sévère
et on n'est pas assez bas on l'a vu dans
les semaines qui ont précédé aujourd'hui
là on a beaucoup parlé de cette question
du harcèlement des agressions sexuelles
ça a été c'était un sujet central dans
l'opinion et c'était un problème
important on avait posé la question il y
avait 91 % des français qui nous disait
que c'était un problème important dans
la société française et même 56% des
femmes qui nous excite est un problème
très important il ya très peu de
questions aux deux sondages sur lesquels
les gens nous disent c'est un problème
important on avait un autre chiffre
53% des femmes ont déjà été victimes
d'après lé d'un harcèlement ou d'une
agression sexuelle donc c'est quelque
chose qui compte dans la société
française et en même temps emmanuel
macron fait a plutôt raison d'une
manière générale de ne pas souhaiter une
société de la délation et de mettre ce
petit haut là puisque c'est une attente
de la société française dans les débats
on a beaucoup entendu très peu de gens
ont considéré que c'était un faux
problème bien sûr mais beaucoup ont eu
peur tout de suite qu on aille vers une
société à l'américaine société de
délation
donc il répond avec ce discours
équilibré elle répond assez bien et est
audible finalement cette partie de la
population qui roule à la tension où est
ce qu'on va jusqu'où on va aller mais
c'est ce que vous pensez qu'on peut
revenir à à un traitement plus plus
apaisé on va dire de ce sujet aux biens
non c'est trop tard il ya eu tellement
de tension il ya aussi tellement de
d'affaires qui sont sortis de
témoignages que que ce on a crantée
quelque chose sur lequel on reviendra
pas avec ce risque peut-être de
d'opposition ou de méfiance réciproque
entre hommes et femmes
moi je voulais surtout réagir quand on
emploie le terme de société à
l'américaine parce que ça s'est passé
c'est venu des états unis et du
comportement d' harvey weinstein et donc
c'est venu en fait de cela c'est le
producteur hollywoodien c'est venu de ce
qui se passait à hollywood et en fait on
peut afficher quelque chose et puis
avoir une forte hypocrisie c'est à dire
qu'on peut dire que on est dans une
société à l'américaine et puis on sait
ce qui s'est passé avec harvey weinstein
le sujet c'est les relations de pouvoir
la question de la hiérarchie la question
des lieux où se passent les choses et
donc moi ce que j'espère je sais pas si
on va j'espère qu'on n'ira pas à une
société hypocrite et j'espère que les
femmes d'abord chacune comme individu et
comme personnes sont capables d'avoir de
bonnes relations avec les hommes
je ne le réduit pas mes relations avec
les hommes ou les relations des hommes
et des femmes à la question de mettre la
main aux fesses
mais la question de savoir mettre le
holà certaines femmes sans doute n'ont
pas la possibilité ça peut dépendre de
leur situation sociale de leur éducation
de leur capacité à dire non vous savez
c'est des choses au fond assez
individuelle et donc que la société et
l'état
avec des politiques publiques soit
capable de faire en sorte qu'ils aient
pas d'hypocrisie qu'on passe pas notre
temps les des hashtags mais qu'en fait
la réalité soit que les violences
diminue c'est ça l'essentiel
ça c'est quelque chose qu'on peut
partager entre hommes et femmes mais est
ce que vous vous êtes vous trouvez que
cinq ans de prison
soixante quinze mille euros même si
c'est une peine théorique à on sait bien
que les juges vont pas jusque là mais
cccc juste tout c'est beaucoup pour une
main aux fesses dans un escalier non je
pense que je ne commente pas la loi pour
commencer c'est à dire que je ne veux
pas lorsqu'il s'agit de violences
sexuelles ou de harcèlement commencé à
dire ah non la loi va trop loin je pense
que moi je respecte la loi je ferai
c'est quelque chose d'essentiel je ne
commente pas non plus les décisions de
justice et donc j'attends d'eux que la
loi en fait soit dissuasive et qu'elles
permettent de prévenir des gestes qui
serait lorsqu'il ya une situation de
pouvoir je le répète c'est très
différent de ce qui se passe dans la
relation interpersonnelle classique dans
un couple par exemple ces deux choses
différentes
la situation de pouvoir peut d'ailleurs
existait aussi dans le couple donc la
question c'est que quand on est plus
fait physiquement on se retrouve pas
dans une situation en fond on va subir
une violence physique
il faut tenir compte vous savez delà les
inégalités
physiques existent comme les inégalités
sociales et la loi est là pour faire en
sorte qu'on soit tous à égalité sur la
question c'est est-ce que cette campagne
publicitaire qui enfin public plus que
publicité à cette campagne s'inscrit
dans des campagnes ultra violente c'est
devenu une tradition en france mais
aussi bien pour arrêter de fumer que
pour qu'ils aient moins d'accidents de
la route
c'est une philosophie et de l'esprit
voilà pu frapper très fort avec une
menace très violente pour faire avancer
effectivement la dissuasion la
dissuasion comme c'était le cas
notamment pour le pour le tabac des
choses comme ça la question est 'que
c'est aussi une incitation pour les
féministes ultra comme caroline de haas
pour dire mais il faut aller vraiment
jusqu'à 7 jusqu'à c
jusque là pour que vous compreniez bien
vous les hommes que vous êtes vous êtes
sous le coup de cette de cette punition
c'est vraiment la frontière qui existe
dans quelle mesure ça n'incite pas à
aller vraiment très très loin dans la
alors que je pense qu'elle n'est pas
prévu pour dire vous allez faire cinq
ans de prison si vous notez une main aux
fesses et font dire il ya ce risque là
parce que on va pas changer les
mentalités avec une loi aujourd'hui en
trois jours en trois mois on sait très
bien et manuela qu'on le sait on change
les mentalités commencent à changer sur
la cigarette en prenant des décisions ou
ana ivanovic la voiture à paris en
prenant des décisions très violente
et puis après en aménageant en
assouplissant ce qu'elle a oublié de
faire elle mais c'est je crois que c'est
un peu c'est un peu l'idée de cette
campagne de comparaison je serai pas là
surgit parce que mes amis dhabi toujours
en parler parce que c'est quelqu'un
d'important c'est une femme important
qu'on s'intéresse de très près ce qu'est
ce qu'elle fait merci je vous propose de
passer aux républicains on a appris ce
week-end j'étais chez nos confrères du
jdd hier que trois responsables des
républicains deux ministres ou
secrétaires d'état à gérald darmanin et
sébastien lecornu et un député thierry
solère quitté ce parti pour rejoindre la
république en marche
est ce une clarification ou une trahison
laurent wauquiez le possible peut-être
même probable futur président des
républicains à son avis sur la question
regardez il l'a dit hier au grand rendez
vous d'europe1 il ya une phrase de
françois mitterrand que j'aime bien sur
le chemin de la trahison
il n'y a que le fleuve de la honte à
traverser eh bien ils ont fini par
traverser ce fleuve
on comprend bien aujourd'hui que l'on
réalité toutes leurs démarches ont été
dictées que par des petits calculs et au
fond pourquoi est-ce qu'ils partent en
marche
ils partent en marche parce qu'ils ont
échoué ils partent en mars parce que
plus personne ne vaudou et qu'ils n'ont
pas réussi à torpiller la droite moi
j'avance je laisse les esprits chagrins
dans le rétroviseur
anne fulda il est temps de se calmer
peut-être non oui là il n'est pas très
convaincant il faut bien dire parce que
c'est vrai que c'est pas les plus
mauvais qui partent se trouve que ce
retour explique assez pas à la hauteur
quoi franchement bon je trouve que c'est
une clarification ils ont choisi je
trouve que c'est c'est dire qu'ils vont
à la soupe c'est un peu réducteur un peu
vous ça apporte pas grand chose on peut
dire que c'est une forme de courage
aussi de clarification même si
effectivement ils sont au pouvoir mais
je trouve que son accès facile
aujourd'hui c'est sûr que c'est plus
facile je sais pas ce qu'ils vont à la
soupe où bon nombre courageux bon ils
sont pas courageuse certes ce n'est pas
un acte de courage mais enfin cesser ces
grandes formules s'être cette citation
de mitterrand un peu éculé franchement
cela passe ça n'apporte pas grand chose
on s'est remis en marche où ils se
feront une petite place peut-être parce
que c'est dingue on parlera aujourd'hui
qui n'a pas qui n'a pas beaucoup de dm
était très très très flamboyant et se
disent que peut-être à terme et là il
faut pas mégoter sur leurs convictions
je pense qu'effectivement la république
en marche correspond à leurs convictions
mais moi ce qui me chagrine c'est que je
pense qu'elle correspond à leurs
convictions depuis six mois et que ce
serait parce qu'ils ont constaté qu'il y
avait 1-1 possibilité de créer un espace
entre la république en marche et les
républicains tels qu'ils ont l'air de se
dessiner avec wauquiez à leur tête qui
se débat tant qu'à faire face on va être
coincé entre les deux autant aller aux
républicains en main à la république en
marche pas danser c'est ça qui me gêne
dans leur démarche tardive
sans parler de la questure de solaire
etc semblent vouloir garder à tout prix
pour les prochains mois c'est un autre
sujet mais en fait ils avalisent d'une
certaine manière un état de fait depuis
six mois et c'est parce qu'ils ont et
lavaud qui a quand même raison de dire
c'est parce qu'elle n'arrive pas à faire
que les constructif qui se tapent dessus
en permanence à l'assemblée nationale
entre les udi etc il n'y a pas un autre
espace à côté des modem qui est possible
donc ils rejoignent logiquement la
république en marche et encore une fois
il me semble ça correspond alors à leurs
idées
il n'y a pas de là dessus il n'y a pas
de discussion alors vous parliez des
nouveaux espaces il ya un nouvel espace
qui s'appelle agir agir c'est un
mouvement qui est chouette ian poulter
qui va peut-être je sais pas si vous
allez rejoindre agir en tout cas il ya
quelqu'un qui l'a rejoint
figurez-vous le parti de franck riester
c'est jean baptiste émergents du
figaro.fr qui s'est inscrit ou qui a
tenté de prendre sa carte dans ce parti
racontez-nous l'empathie fabrice terre a
promis une approche plus collaborative
est plus spontané
j'ai donc fait une investigation de
terrain en restant derrière mon
ordinateur et j'ai voulu tester donc le
site agir donc je vais vous verrez sur
le visuel que j'ai prévu le site d'agir
actuellement il n'y a pas de site
internet c'est juste un formulaire à
remplir que j'ai rempli avec beaucoup de
sérieux et agilité grâce à mon clavier
est en fait l'unique y répond ce qu'on
nous donne c'est merci aux moutons vous
contactera très prochainement on vous
écrira j'attends donc vous contacter
amanda écrit agir en gros on appuie sur
réagir ça mène vers les réseaux sociaux
donc je suis allé voir les réseaux
sociaux sur facebook un excellent
interview de franck cristers publié dans
le figaro vendredi dernier à peu près de
158 réaction donc c'est un peu plus à
258 laïque ce qui est quand même assez
faible sur twitter un compte qui a été
créée mal en fait ils se sont trompés au
moment du lancement donc il vous avez
deux comptes
vous avez le agir underscore ldc vous
avez aussi le agir ldc mou on sait pas
trop quel est le plus officiel j'ai pris
plus officiel qui a été renvoyée par le
site
mais si vous avez dans l'autre sens vous
renvoie quand même sur le site donc bon
c'est encore un peu cafouilleux et donc
sur le site fait sur la page facebook
ont une publication disent que c'est un
nouvel espace politique qui vient de
s'ouvrir ne vous seront le lieu de débat
de l'infirmation de nos idées et de
l'action j'attends avec impatience le
mail qu'il fallait être envoyées par
agir ce que je n'ai pas encore reçu et
je pense que je lancerai dans quelques
semaines monsieur ensuite aller voir sur
twitter ils ont créé le hashtag réagir
ça tombe bien c'est le bon mot 2000
utilisation depuis le week-end dernier
donc naturellement sur le hashtag est à
fond cristers qui se félicite du
lancement de son parti politique qui
donne encore un parti politique j'ai
découvert un emmanuel alors les manuels
et très heureux de la création de agir
il trouve que les constructif ne doit
pas conduire à l'adhésion automatique
ol et om la députée laure de la raudière
qui elle vient de revoir rejoindre agir
trouve que la fuite chez elle à l'om ne
correspond pas aux attentes des
électeurs
or
d'une droite qui défend ses valeurs
clairement différente de celle du fn
donc ça c'est l'opposition qu'on voit
quand même beaucoup sur les réseaux
sociaux aussi et enfin la députée
valérie boyer elle qui soutient laurent
wauquiez aurait pu chez républicain
dégaine les masques tombent les tontons
flagueurs s'est éparpillé façon puzzle
entre les la république en marche et
agir ou ailleurs merci jean baptiste
aimé le faire tout ça est un peu
embryonnaire voir voir un peu compliqué
à mettre en place
c'est peut-être parce qu'il n'y a pas
vraiment de d'attentes par rapport à ce
genre de mouvement oui il ya surtout un
espace qui est assez réduit entre les
républicains et la république leur
marche on a du mal à imaginer un parti
même yam il ya même beaucoup de
personnalités politiques qui ont du mal
à faire le choix entre les deux donc on
a du mal à imaginer un parti
supplémentaires la question en fait
c'est comment la droite va se comporter
vis-à-vis des manuels macron puisque sur
les questions de valeurs clairement on
voit la différence mais c'est sur la
partie économique où on voit pas la
différence est là où laurent wauquiez
cherche à se démarquer sur des questions
de valeurs il risque bien de perdre son
deuxième pied la question économique
puisque la majorité des sympathisants de
droite soutiennent les réformes
économiques du gouvernement peuvent même
parfois nous dire ils vont plus loin que
ce qu'on n'a jamais espéré en étant de
sympathisants de droite
nous voilà c'est la question c'est
comment laurent wauquiez s'ils
l'emportent bien et ce qui devrait être
le cas se comportera vis-à-vis dans
marche et notamment sur les questions
économiques parce que c'est ça sera là
tout l'enjeu du futur politique des
républicains si jamais le temps que je
sens que l'avenir des républicains ça
vous passionne
oui ça me passionne parce que je voyais
que valérie pécresse l'a a donné un
entretien assez intéressant où l emploi
au monde
elle emploie exactement les mêmes
arguments que ceux qui sont utilisés par
solaire et consorts sur les lorsqu'il
était roux constructif constructif
plutôt creux constructif mais je pense
que reconstructive et c'est ça ou
réagissant je ne sais pas en tout cas il
ya quelque chose sur une espèce de jeu
de mistigri sur les arguments que je
trouve intéressant c'est à dire que en
fonction et ce qui montre que c'est
quand même beaucoup d'opportunisme c'est
à dire qu'en fonction de l'endroit où on
veut rester ou l'endroit on veut partir
ou l'endroit on veut créer on emploie
tel ou tel argument et moi je pense que
appartenir à une famille politique
qu'on soit sympathisants conçoit
électeurs etc c'est aussi quelque chose
de l'ordre
excusez moi c'est une époque
d'infidélité mais de l'ordre de là
inuits et des convictions et c'est donc
moi je trouve que il faut qu'il fasse
très attention parce que à force d'être
l'appui l'appui là ils vont peut-être se
décrédibiliser enfin je prends le pari
et j'espère qu'ils vont se
décrédibiliser j'assume avec l'idée et
moi je trouve que le choix d'aller à la
république en marche pour le coup je
trouve très cohérent je trouve bien pour
eux après je dirais pas cher jean
christophe que c'est la conviction ça
s'appelle un plan de carrière
donc il faut quand même appeler un chat
un chat c'est à dire que je suis pas sûr
qu'à la république en marche
hormis la pensée du président macron il
est temps que ça aujourd'hui un projet
très structuré en revanche je suis sûr
que c'est l'endroit où il faut être
si on veut arriver au gouvernement
confirmé son poste à la questure et
c'est donc je crois que c'est un bon
plan je ne crois pas que ça veut dire où
l'ex avec une conviction et c'est là
qu'en ville son maire de la république
en je ne sais pas en tout cas j'espère
que la conviction politique continue à
exister dans le nouveau monde dans
lequel nous sommes
et je prends le pari que peut-être
d'autres personnes mettre en place des
éléments qui au fond nous dirons le
sujet c est ce que le clivage
gauche-droite continuer à exister
je pense que qu'on soit de droite ou de
gauche on peut se poser la question que
quand j'écoute laurent wauquiez qui fait
la triangulation en ayant épluché
fébrilement françois mitterrand avant la
radio je trouve ça pathétique
je pense qu'il a qu'à dire laurent
wauquiez pense ça et non pas françois
mitterrand a dit que je crois la
trahison
donc il ya quelque chose autour de la
continuité politique et du clivage
gauche droite est ce qu il existera
encore dans six mois mais je prends le
pari que lui et je viendrai le dire ici
je suis comme dirait habitera pour ça
comme des américains la trahison ne
réussit jamais parce que lorsqu'elle
réussit on lui donne un autre nom du
succès mais peut-être peut-être pas
seulement agir parce que franchement
comme nom de réagir monégasque passé
mort né
je réalise sa voyante est-ce que vous
pensez que si comme c'est bhl audible
laurent wauquiez est élu président
républicain il y aura il y aura d'autres
départs comme cela ce que c'est le début
d'une grande hémorragie ou pas grande je
pense par mais il y aura sûrement une
clarification il ya 2 mais bon on voit
déjà ceux qui partiront sait déjà quels
sont les clivages ski ski valais les
différencier les uns des autres mais moi
je trouve qu'on a le droit de quitter
une famille si on n'est plus d'accord
avec sa famille d'une famille politique
une famille enfin une famille politique
en tout cas quand on n'est plus d'accord
avec l'orientation de cette famille on a
tout à fait le droit
alors ici ça peut effectivement servi en
carrière mais on va le droit de la
quitter je ne vois pas il n'y a pas de
ya pas de drame
et puis mon cette impression là comme ça
ça donne une quand même une impression
de confusion de petite cuisine politique
avec tous ces mouvements personne
connaît on s'y retrouve pas qu'il
connaît franck riester enfin bon c'est
ça fait pas vraiment avancer les
je suis bi en tout cas ça prouve que que
vraiment la victoire d'emmanuel macron a
considérablement de redistribuer les
cartes désorganisé la vie politique
française et ça continue quoi les îles
et les répliques continuent comme y'a
pas de mal a encore besoin à emmanuel
malheureusement si ce n'est jean luc
mélenchon et où baby et encore jean les
présents sont semble-t-il et à un
opposant simple moins flamboyant
qu'avant merci cescut pour cette 33e
apporter sur un plateau les la france
insoumise était ce week end à clermont
ferrand pour sa convention ragon
beaucoup discuter de leurs projets mais
on a le sentiment et émilie leclerc va
me dire si c'est juste un sentiment que
le mélenchon flamboyant opposant unica
macron un peu un peu de peine là c'est
une impression seulement il a un petit
peu plomb dans l'ailé effectivement on a
on a posé la question aux français sa
popularité la semaine dernière et il est
aujourd'hui à 36% il a perdu six points
en l'espace de deux mois donc c'est une
baisse assez conséquente assez rapide
alors il ya deux raisons à cela la
première c'est que il ya eu les
manifestations contre le travail qu'ils
ont été plutôt un échec et la 80 % des
français le constate
et puis la deuxième raison c'est
évidemment les dissensions internes et
les affaires et qui sont
particulièrement choquant pour les
français quand elle concerne des membres
de la france a soumises qui se réclament
de la défense du peuple de face aux
élites et quand elles sont pris à eux
mêmes dans le par les affaires et ben ça
pose un temps avant les problèmes de
logement des affaires notamment de
daniel alterné exactement l'ensemble
deux de ces de ces problèmes de ces
problématiques pause
m la france info mise en difficulté en
ce moment et malgré tout il reste quand
même jean luc mélenchon reste le
meilleur opposant à emmanuel macron
c'est un peu au royaume des aveugles les
borgnes sont rois
puisque vous n'avez pas beaucoup de
personnalités politiques de premier plan
qui s'oppose bien emmanuel macron marine
le pen est toujours en difficulté depuis
la présidentielle
laurent wauquiez peine à prendre de
l'essor dans l'opinion et puis au parti
socialiste il n'y a plus grand monde
pour se poser à emmanuel macron donc le
seul opposant et vrais opposants au
gouvernement ces journées mais le show
aux yeux des français
si je fais pour vous c'est juste un
petit trou d'air ou l'échec de la
mobilisation contre la loi travail va
laisser des traces
je pense que c'est pas seulement un trou
d'air que la question c'est plutôt la
balle est dans le camp de mélenchon et
son mouvement sur est ce qu'ils sont
capables de faire des propositions pour
l'exercice du pouvoir
je pense qu'à partir du moment où on
entre dans le dur de l'exercice de la
responsabilité
et là dessus il y avait un entretien
assez intéressant avec françois ruffin
qui partage avec emmanuel macron le fait
d'être originaire d'amiens
et sinon on ne peut pas tout autre chose
mais
c'était une boutade mais la question
c'est françois ruffin lui même avec une
espèce de jeu trouve de sincérité qui
manque trop dans le monde politique a
dit au fond n'est pas prêt à exercer le
pouvoir et alors tout de suite hein mais
que va penser mélenchon comme si c'était
le grand chef le grand timonier
je pense qu'il faut que mélenchon
apprennent aussi organisés autour de lui
une équipe qui soit pas seulement des
gens qui au fond était très proche de
lui mais qui ont révélé une légèreté des
moeurs
des moeurs économique et la deuxième
chose c'est qu'il s'intéresse maintenant
à des propositions alternatives sinon il
ne peut pas espérer à mon sens restait
le seul opposant et il a devant lui
les européennes notamment sur lesquels
il peut faire quelque chose il a
toujours été assez bons sur la critique
de l'europe ce qui est un point fort
d'un sauté française mais macron va
défendre l'europe
mélenchon va proposer autre chose hélas
il sera devant une nécessité qu'est ce
qu'ils feraient s'ils exerçaient le
pouvoir je trouve qu'il ne remplit
absolument pas et c'est pas les boutades
et les bons mots et le fait de dire que
demain tout ira mal pour emmanuel macron
qui peut tenir lieu de programme
et puis ya peut-être aussi le l'impact
de des fractures qui existent à
l'intérieur de ce parti sur la laïcité
on se souvient que danièle obono la
députée de paris a soutenu et on va on
va on va à le réécouter dans quelques
instants
ce qu'elle appelle la pratique de la non
mixité c'est à dire des réunions par
exemple des réunions syndicales qui
seraient interdites aux blancs ou
interdites au noir on a on voit arriver
là ddd pratique était absolument inconnu
jusqu'à présent mais qui pour la députée
de paris la france insoumise serait des
pratiques et bien justifié regarder la
pratique de la non mixité n'est pas
dangereux dans le sens où c'est une
pratique qui répondent à des besoins un
moment donné deux catégories par exemple
je reviens encore l'exemple du mouvement
féministe à un moment donné les par
exemple les personnes qui sont victimes
de violence sur sur un certain nombre de
questions vont avoir un besoin à un
moment donné de dire il va falloir qu'on
puisse discuter en se sentant en
confiance et du coup il faut le faire
avec voilà des personnes avec lesquelles
on s'identifie comme partageant le même
type de problème
avant d'écouter votre réaction à cette
prise de position je vous proposant
d'écouter une autre d'un autre député de
la france est soumise c'est alexis
corbière député de la seine-saint-denis
qui réagissait lui à une proposition
d'une réunion syndicale ben justement
qui serait
non mme x comme on dit aujourd'hui et
évidemment il est totalement contre
enfin évidemment
évidemment quand on connaît regardé par
définition une réunion syndicale je
souhaite qu'elles sont ouvertes à tous
les syndiqués et je ne souhaite pas que
l'on mette en place un système en
quelque sorte je vais dire on peut
simplement en fonction de la couleur de
la peau on peut se réunir ou pas je ne
suis pas d'accord moi je fusionne
universal distant républicain je pense
que ce qui est formidable dans notre
pays c'est qu'il est basé sur la
proclamation des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen les hommes naissent et demeurent
libres et égaux en droit et si on rentre
dans un système fut son nom du fait
qu'il ya des discriminations qu'il faut
combattre que en quelque sorte
des réunions sont ouvertes à certains et
pas à d'autres je crois que nous avons
perdu donc je ne suis pas d'accord avec
cela
chacun sa puissance et c'est pas une
polémique ça c'est quand même une vraie
une vraie opposition de fond sur un
sujet important oui parce que en fait la
france est soumise au coeur d'un certain
nombre d'ambiguïtés
il ya des ambiguïtés effectivement
politico intellectuelle comme et celle
là en est une très forte entre un alexis
corbière qui effectivement sur les
sujets de la laïcité de l'islam qui est
vraiment très très clair sur ces sujets
là et danièle obono qui vient de ce
milieu associatif qui flirtait parfois
avec avec les mouvements proches des
salafistes
le parti des indigènes avec 6 corbières
a dit clairement que c'était un parti
antisémite et raciste il l'a dit c'est
pas pas extrêmement qu'il a dirigé et au
sein de son parti il ya sept personnes
un dernier lot bono qui n'arrivent pas à
rompre avec ce milieu dont elle est
issue
sans avoir conscience qui est maintenant
les députés de la nation et que il ya
certaines amitiés qui sont un petit peu
difficile mais au-delà de ça la france a
soumis c'est aussi l'ambiguïté sur la
notion de chef
lucie laborde et trailer le le problème
de mélenchon qui était déjà son problème
d'un campagne électorale s'est il ya qui
derrière lui pour être ministre à
l'époque on pouvait pas imaginer qu'un
axe corbières ou une clémentine autain
soit ministre peut-être que depuis
qu'ils ont fait du travail parlementaire
ils ont pris une épaisseur est si fine
réalité désir mais aujourd'hui on se dit
au delà de la façon de d'exercer le
pouvoir c'est pas avant au moins quatre
ans s'il se représente
qu'il ya derrière mélenchon et quand on
voit qu'à la convention de clermont
ferrand il arrive sur scène seul n'y a
que lui qui fait le grand discours et
cetera alors que lui les premiers à dire
je ne suis qu'un passeur je suis pas du
tout le chef il ya une ambiguïté là au
coeur de ceux de la france a soumises
qui est réel donc il ya toutes ces
ambiguïtés qui joue la troisième qui est
très forte c'est que oui ce sont des
très bons opposants mais inefficace et
on le sait depuis le début ils sont 17 à
l'assemblée nationale vous ne pouvez pas
vous opposer à la loi travail quand une
majorité parlementaire vous pouvez pas à
poser un certain nombre de lois quand
vous n'êtes que 17 donc vous pouvez de
crier très fort par les très forts
courir les plateaux télé mais les
français sont pas dupes ils voient que
les lois passent bon c'est bien d'avoir
mélenchon qui hurle mais ça ne sert à
rien donc cette ambiguïté d'être très
forts médiatiquement et symboliquement
et d'avoir aucune efficacité politique
il on s'ouvre et ça donne cette espèce
de blues qui a france insoumise entre
effectivement ces ambiguïtés sur
certains sujets comme la laïcité
le fait d'avoir une totale initiative
inefficacité politique tout ça joue dans
le fait que les français se disent
et puis on a parlé un petit peu dé
l'ombre des affaires ou même une raquel
garrido peu importe ce soit une bonne
mauvaise raison mais l'idée qu'elle
travaille pour bolloré tous et en ayant
été porte-parole insoumis ça crée un
malaise dans l'impression d'un mouvement
qui n'est plus cohérent qui n'est plus
sur ces bases idéologiques et mélenchon
tente de garder une espèce d'une unité
de façade parce que il a besoin de tout
le monde parce que c'est un parti vous
avez des gens qui sont venus pour des
raisons écologiques ya beaucoup
d'écologistes ont rejoint la france et
sioniste parce qu'il pensait que ce
serait plus efficace qu europe ecologie
les verts donc qui sont venus parce que
c'était un mouvement vraiment laïque
d'autres qui sont venus le vote musulman
a joué en sa faveur dans les banlieues
et tout ça fait une sorte d'auberge
espagnole qui aujourd'hui montre ses
limites
allez vous remonter le moral la france a
soumis ce qui nous écoutent sur moi donc
je pense qu'il ya un problème de
concernant la personnalité même de
mélenchon d'ailleurs il a eu une phrase
il a dit l'âge d'or de la politique
c'est fini en fait passé c'est très
révélateur et ça explique pourquoi ça ne
marche pas parce que c'est pas un homme
de parti mélenchon c'est pas un homme
qui s'est effectivement structures et
des troupes organiser un party faire
monter un tel
c'est pas son lui ce qu'il aime c'est
les batailles les grandes batailles et
les c'est un tribun voilà donc donc là
en fait je crois qu'ils sont ici ils
sont bêtes quoi enfin c'est pas un job
taillé pour lui deux chefs de parti
quand il n'y a pas d'élection à terme
c'est il aime les batailles il aime les
grandes causes
et là on se sent désarçonnée est presque
triste est cette phrase l'âge d'or de la
politique c'est fini c'est à dire qu'en
gros il conseille aux militants de 2
prenez une
une approche plus de proximité pour pour
pour faire connaître leur politique
c'est c'est quelque chose qui qui ne lui
correspond pas lui c'est l'homme des
grands mots des grandes têtes alors
peut-être oseriez vous européenne où on
n'est pas tout de suite là il va se
réveiller mais mais je pense qu'il est
malheureux et donc effectivement il est
ici c'est paris s'est pas mobilisé ses
troupes
il était donné de le faire je pense
qu'il est mal européen annonçant qu'il
n'a pas envie de trancher sur ce sujet
de entre d'un côté sa branche laïque et
de l'autre celle qui est plus
communautariste
ils sont à présent c'est quand même très
difficile après par rapport à ce que
disait anne fulda je pense qu'il est
aussi et désarçonnés par le fait que le
parti socialiste n'existe plus je
rappelle quand même une chose c'est
qu'il a il a grandi dans le parti
socialiste et que combattent le parti
socialiste était son grand combat donc
aujourd'hui il est orphelin d'un grand
combat politique contre son propre camp
et la deuxième chose qu'on peut dire
c'est que sur la question de alors ce
que vous qualifiez jean-christophe de
laïcité
en fait c'est la laïcité la question de
l'égalité hommes femmes la question la
discrimination aussi donc il ya toute
une série de choses qui sont
interconnectés et c'est extrêmement
difficile évidemment de dire de
synthétiser et de dire voilà je refuse
ça alors qu'on vous dit mais ce sont les
plus faibles qui en ont besoin
l'argumentaire est assez fallacieux
d'ailleurs rapproché sa wii de danièle
obono parce qu'elle dit au fond je
rapproche de la façon dont les femmes se
réunissait entre elles quand les hommes
étaient puissants et les féministes
faisait comme ça c'est pas vrai du tout
d'abord je pense que en moins une femme
si je puis me permettre
on sait grosso modo canton comment on
peut se réunir entre femmes
moi je ne sais pas qui sont les
personnes qui sont dans ces ateliers
parce que non blancs je ne sais pas ce
que ça veut dire est-ce que c'est
sélection sur le physique le nom
le père la mère enfin je trouve que
c'est un concept qui est absolument
montreux
donc on a quelque chose qui ne
fonctionne pas et je trouve que le
parallèle avec ce que faisaient les
féministes moi il ne me plaît pas du
tout c'est le projet horizon c'est leur
c'est une sorte de réhabilitation d'une
forme d'apartheid et puis donc ses
foucades que mélenchon n'est pas une une
réaction plus plus tranchée parce que
c'est c'est quand même ça va on imagine
syndicat avait voulu organiser des
réunions maccarthysme sont en principe
dans les cuisses l'ordinaire c'est qu'en
même temps on sent une espèce de
sincérité dans la manière dont elle
défend l'indéfendable donc il ya aussi
quelque chose qui participe sans doute
d'un vécu individuel et quand corbières
dix mois chauds universaliste c'est
intéressant parce que ça montre que
l'amérique la l'universalisme ça se
construit c'est une éducation et c'est
pas forcément quelque chose qui vient
spontanément ce qu'elle prône sait
parfaitement inaudible dans la société
française cela pourrait l'être d'autant
moins dans des pays en dehors anglo
saxons on a l'habitude d'être parent
communautés de vivre communautés l'une à
côté de l'autre et de se regrouper entre
en france ça n'existe pas c'est
inaudible pour les français ça ne peut
pas on peut pas du mal à imaginer
comment un certain nombre de français
seraient convaincus
une partie peut être dans le monde
associatif mais ça se limitera sa wii et
paul nous dit c'est le problème de ces
mouvement fédérateur mais incontrôlable
effectivement en tout cas difficile à
contrôler pour leur patron parlons si
vous le voulez bien du glyphosate le ce
produit qui est autorisé pour cinq ans
finalement c'est la décision de l'union
européenne qui vient de qui vient de
sortir le glyphosate donc cela permet
d'éliminer les mauvaises herbes c'est de
la base de ce qu'on appelle le round up
produit semble-t-il extrêmement efficace
mais assez contesté alors ce qui est
étonnant c'est pour ça que j'aimerais
bien qu'on en parle un peu c'est que la
france était contre la reconduction de
cette autorisation pour cinq ans mais il
ya quand même eu 18 états membres dont
des pays dont la sensibilité écologiste
est connu comme l'allemagne qui ont dit
eh ben oui on repart pour cinq ans et
puis on verra bien peut-être que
finalement c'est pas si dangereux que ça
voilà c'est moi qui ajoute mais
j'imagine que c'est ça la justification
de leurs décisions alors le sismique
qu'est ce qui se passe c'est ce que est
ce que tous les autres sont vendus à
monsanto qui est le fabricant de ce
produit ou est ce que il ya quand même
encore un débat possible non
le danger de ce produit il ya plusieurs
choses on peut discuter du tifo that et
puis aussi parler de ce qui s'est passé
à bruxelles parce que c'est une
c'est une décision qui est inattendu
c'est à dire qu'on a on pensait ça fait
des mois que ça dure et on pensait que
la proposition de la commission qui est
de reconfirmer glyphosate pour cinq ans
allaient être repoussés parce que la
france en association avec l'allemagne
n'en voulait pas et puis entre temps en
interne en allemagne les négociations
pour former une coalition dans laquelle
les écologistes allemands auraient joué
un rôle important ont échoué et donc la
position l'allemagne a fait basculer les
choses c'est à dire que la position de
la commission a été adopté parce que
l'allemagne a changé de position elle a
voté pour alors qu'elle s'était abstenue
donc ce qui est très intéressant c'est
que moi je trouve que d'abord là il ya
une défaite française par rapport aux
franco allemand qui était quelque chose
sur lequel on parle beaucoup des manuels
macro et d'angela merkel ça traduit le
flottement aujourd'hui en allemagne
et puis ça traduit le fait
qu'aujourd'hui en allemagne il ya des
intérêts économiques puissants qui sont
pour le fait que le roundup continue à
pouvoir exister que le glyphosate soit
confirmée donc on voit une sorte je
trouve de d'affrontements qui paraît
très visible entre les intérêts
économiques
les alliances qui existait entre la
france et l'allemagne et puis pour
parler du glyphosate puisque vous voulez
là dessus un avis très scientifique
avoir un avis avant les muscs et ce qui
est très intéressant c'est que il ya
plusieurs études et que d'abord
l'organisation mondiale de la santé dit
quand même que c'est un produit
potentiellement cancérigènes donc ça a
été
démontré par plusieurs études mais
continue à y avoir des débats sur le
front des études et c'est notamment un
truc qui a été dit pour dire qu'il
fallait leur confirmer la vérité c'est
que on sait qu'il est cancérigène mais
en revanche il ya des milliards des
centaines de milliards qui sont en jeu
parce que le roundup est un produit
extrêmement utilisés dans l'agriculture
européenne et que le supprimer ça oblige
à toute une série de choses ça s'appelle
la transition écologique
c'est à dire que ça oblige à cultiver
différemment a retrouvé des manières de
faire pour le désherbage etc ça oblige
aussi donc à reconfigurer économiquement
les exploitations les équilibres à la
fois comment dirais-je de l'ensemble du
secteur et puis individuellement et puis
ça aurait obligé sur le plan juridique
si jamais on interdisait le glyphosate
ça aurait obligé à prendre des risques
juridiques parce que monsanto et les
entreprises concernées menacé de traîner
la commission européenne l'union
européenne en justice dont il y avait
des histoires de gros sous
vous pensez que c'est seulement la peur
jean christophe buisson parce qu'il ya
aussi tdd des enquêtes qu'ils disent
mais le glyphosate on n'a aucune preuve
d'ailleurs on dit bien qu'il est
potentiellement cancérigènes mais c'est
pas il n'y a pas de certitude absolue si
non alors c'est triste de se dire que
c'est pour des raisons politiques
finalement l'allemagne a renoncé parce
que ça veut dire qu'effectivement ces
études
personne n'en tient vraiment content
mais pourquoi cela où logent chez une
petite réserve sur ce que vous n'aimez
bien c'est potentiellement cancérigènes
potentiellement c'est à dire vois ça
dépend d'une dose âge ils proviennent du
dosage c'est tous les sens du sujet
c'est à dire que je crois qu'il y avait
une étude qui montre et qu'on parlait
quand il y avait 2000 microgrammes dans
dans des lentilles 2000 microgrammes ça
fait peur et c'est en fait il faudrait
manger 7 kg de lentilles pour arriver à
la dose de milliers de microgrammes qui
fait que c'est potentiellement
cancérigènes si on en mange tout servir
tous les joueurs tous à vis tous les
jours non mais c'est ça c'est des
chiffres 2000 microgrammes on dit que ça
fait beaucoup et en fait en proportion
c'est un seuil à ne pas dépasser mais si
on mange des lentilles qui ont 2000
microgrammes tous les jours de sa vie et
sept kilos de pâtes etc
donc le problème c'est potentiellement
cancérogènes comme des milliers de
produits
mais il faut savoir laquelle dos ça
devient cancérigènes et accumulé avec
d'autres produits qui sont effectivement
potentiellement cancérigènes donc et par
ailleurs il ya effectivement dans une
étude amérique
dont le figaro a parlé la semaine
dernière se fait sur des paysans
américains on s'aperçoit que sur sur les
paysans qui ont été atteints d'un cancer
ça n'était pas un majoritairement pour
l' usage de dcl il faudra donc c'est
vrai que on a l'impression qu'il ya des
cas des mots qui sont prononcés de façon
violente solennelle définitive et qu on
en conclut que c'est quand c'est même
moi je n'arrive pas à croire que sur 28
pays s'il y en a effectivement disent
qu'ils votent content même si ça fait
pas une majorité suffisante ce n'est que
parce qu'ils sont totalement vendu aux
grands lobbys industriels à 18 qui sont
à 18 clients et qui revêt une petite
réaction rapide
je pense que le poids des lobbys
économiques au niveau aujourd'hui des
états est très fort on peut le regretter
mais ça explique sans doute 90% de la
décision après sur la question de
l'étude américaine et des études ce qui
est d'abord il faut savoir si on regarde
les agriculteurs ou l'ensemble de la
population
donc effectivement l'exposition est
beaucoup plus du côté des agriculteurs
que de nous qui allons manger des
lentilles ou pas d'ailleurs
donc moi si je me place du côté des
agriculteurs sur l'étude américaine qui
effectivement est une étude
scientifiquement assez la méthode est
bonne sauf sur un point qui est très
important c'est que les cc déclaratives
cirque a pas de mesures médicales sur la
manière dont on détermine si les gens
sont exposés ou pas ou il faut that à
dire que c'est l'agriculteur qui dit
voilà je suis exposé ou pas je suis pas
sûr que chacun soit en mesure de dire
s'il est vraiment exposés à de très
fortes doses
c'est assez difficile on fait ça tous
les jours on arrose les champs avec le
glyphosate avec le roundup
donc il ya un sujet sur l'étude et la
méthode le déclaratif et il ya d'autre
part puisqu'on et on se bat à coups
d'études avec jean christophe et une
étude américaine qui sort la semaine
prochaine et je suis sûr que le figaro
en rendra compte qu'il va dire qu'au
contraire il ya deux fois plus de
cancers quand on est exposé will chose à
dévoiler en exclusivité et gilles ajoute
publié dans quel journal parce que ce
qui fait aussi la différence et le sait
la qualité du journal qualité
scientifique journal qui publie cette
étude est là c'est un journal soldats
américains sur le temps que ses bras
dans le figaro 60 maintenant après le
fils y auraient droit
on allait je vous invite à contacter et
à commentaires de gilles qui nous dit
peu cancérigènes pour les humains mais
il ya aussi des animaux autour
anne fulda heureusement que ce débat n'a
pas lieu avant des élections européennes
parce que ça donne quand même un
sentiment
et d'impuissance et d'incohérences c'est
à dire que bon là qu'est ce qu'on fait
qu'est ce qui va se passer en france
donc on a voté contre mais on va
continuer on continue à importer ce
produit est d'utiliser donc
donc je trouve que ça donne une image
catastrophique de du fonctionnement de
l'europe concrète quoi donc c'est vrai
d'ailleurs et quelle va être la position
de la france là qu'est ce qu'on fait on
continue à importer des leurs en diop et
à l'utiliser est ce que il n'y a pas de
solution alternative pour l'instant donc
c'est à dire qu'on continue à offrir
tout en considérant que ce produit est
probablement cancérogènes que mais elle
dit le ms on continue à le à s'en servir
donc j'ai un oui un vrai malaise ça
donne un sentiment de dun puissance est
vraiment heureusement qu'il ya pas d
élections européennes demain voilà je
vous livre ce commentaire de fouras qui
se demandent si cinq ans est un temps
suffisant pour trouver un succédané
puisque effectivement l'objectif est de
de prolonger le glyphosate le temps de
trouver d'autres herbicides de psy
possible aussi efficace et en tout cas
moins dangereux mais leclerc vous avez
un point de vue sur ce sujet un peu
technique mais néanmoins plus dingue on
a quand même posé la question il ya
quelques semaines sur le glyphosate aux
français et finalement les français sont
pas plus experts que nous et encore
moins mais évidemment donc ils ne savent
pas s'ils me posent at est dangereux ou
pas mais il ya une
un principe qui est très important dans
la société française c'est le principe
de précaution et sur tous les sujets que
ce soit sur le gaz de schiste sur les
ogm tous les sujets de ce type qu'on
sache où qu'on ne sache pas à partir du
moment où il ya un danger
on considère qu'il faut interdire les
produits et là à l'époque on avait posé
cette question il y avait 80 % des
français qui nous disait il faut
interdire le fusad parce que il ya des
doutes sur le sur sa dangerosité
voilà c'est le principe de précaution
qui prévaut dans la société française
pour les pour les français et par
exemple sur l'alcool il raisonne pas
comme ça les gens 11 non c'est ça peut
être dangereux pour la santé c'est alors
je pratique le sujet peut-être qu'il ya
une chose qu'on n'a pas dit c'est que du
côté du parlement européen il ya une il
ya eu l'adoption d'un texte qui disait
qu'il fallait arrêter de glyphosate mais
il ya eu aussi une pétition fait par des
centaines de milliers de citoyens donc
il ya un sujet de mobilisation sociale
et là par rapport à ce que disait anne
fulda est une espèce de décalage entre
des canaux plus démocratiques qui sont
quand même le parlement européen les
citoyens et qui se mobilisent et qui
disent qu'ils n'en veulent pas et y
compris dans les sondages une manière
80% et puis à côté de ça il ya des chefs
de gouvernement qui se réunissent des
ministres était la nounou qui sont le
reflet d'une majorité ces chefs de
gouvernement rejette une majorité
parfois qui est très fort qui ait voulu
vous savez donc et et pardon politique
se d'options on arrête du jour demain
qu'est ce qu'on fait à la place n'ont
hélas l'idée était pacifique cp mention
sensations c'est ça donc il y avait une
période de transition pour pouvoir
justement se reconvertir convertir les
emplois etc
et puis aussi du côté des agriculteurs
il faut apprendre à cultiver
différemment
limite vous avez tout à fait raison
après je regardais les exemples donnés
ça consiste souvent à réapprendre à
travailler la terre et non plus à mettre
des produits donc le succédané je ne
sais pas si c'est la solution
un mot sur une victoire française une
belle victoire celle de la france en
coupe davis
jean christophe buisson pour tout dire
on en a parlé tout à l'heure et vous
avez des choses qui m'a frappé on
m'avait dit j'ai pas spécialiste oui
mais la france a quand même eu de la
chance pourtant à la gagner et bien
gagner
non non mais bien il y avait un
calendrier qui était favorable parce que
les grandes nations les autres grandes
nations de necid de tennis en tout cas
les grandes nations qui bénéficiaient de
joueurs exceptionnels comme la serbie
avec djokovic que la france a battu en
demi finale mais il n'y avait pas
djokovic devait façon je crois que
l'espagne était éliminé nadal ne jouait
pas où la suisse avec federer parce que
les joueurs parfois choisissent plutôt
leur carrière personnelle et de marquer
des points tout le monde l'année et que
jouer la coupe davis leur fait perdre de
l'énergie des entraînements et c'est au
détriment de leur propre carrière et
donc il est assez notable que des
françaises soient mobiles joueurs
français
franco suisse parce que beaucoup
habitent en suisse par parenthèse se
soient mobilisés derrière le drapeau
derrière capitaine qui est un grand
yannick noah qui est un grand fédérateur
un grand capitaine sportifs etc a su les
mobiliser pour pour l'emporter donc il
faut il faut pas avoir le triomphe trop
trop cynique
effectivement c'est une belle victoire
fallait quand david goffin qui était le
meilleur joueur belge est quand même un
niveau au dessus des autres et donc
donc il faut pas négliger sa mais
effectivement on a bénéficié mais comme
d'autres années on a pâti de l'absence
de leaders donc tout ça s'équilibre ça
fait 16 ans qu'on n'avait pas la coupe
davis donc il faut quand même ça
s'arrête jamais il faut pas non plus de
donner l'impression qu'on est la
meilleure nation de tennis du monde
un commentaire sur ce sujet mais hier
sur le tennis-club glyphosate mais non
mais moi à quel âge il a 23 ans
donc il ya un côté on peut être
confiance dans le oui à bat lucas
pouille moi je le trouve extraordinaire
en plus il a gagné devant son public et
il est très jeune et on espère que son
potentiel parce qu'on est des
spécialistes du haut potentiel qui ne
confirme pas donc on espère que l'usap
où il va confirmer son potentiel génère
du nord le doute maintenant ça pose des
questions le fait que la france mais
j'avais entendu aussi que avant la demi
finale on n'avait pas rencontré enfin
les français n'avaient pas joué un
joueur meilleur que le top 40 dans le
top 40 2 mondiale oms a dit quelque
chose il ya une question qui se pose
aussi c'est la laideur cup je crois
qu'ils vous savez sur le modèle du golfe
qui va confronter les états unis et leur
et le continent américain et le
continent européen et qui se développe
et qui pourrait bien remplacer la coupe
davis
si ça continue ainsi louis si les grands
joueurs bout de la compétition et ben en
tout cas on leur a gagné avant qu'elle
ait été supprimée merci à tous restez
connectés pour la plus grande joie de
l'uci lui nous allons retrouver dans un
instant et les émaux échange avec
vincent roux pour parler du style macron
et de ce paradoxe entre une méthode de
gouvernement assez autoritaire peut-être
même archaïques selon zemmour
alors que la politique elle même est
assez moderne vous retrouver ça dans un
instant bonsoir à tous
[Musique]